Now this course is part of
the App Entrepreneurship Nanodegree.
Lots of entrepreneurs work in teams but
many also work alone, so
it's important to think about which
of these circles of feedback you can
access as an individual.
To think about that,
let's first look at how you access
each of the circles of feedback.
The first circle is pretty simple.
If you work at a company, you can walk
down the hole to ask someone or if
you're working on your own, you can ask
a fried to sit down on a couch with you.
Since you only need 10 or 15 minutes of
someone's time to get a good sense how
they would react to your app,
you can usually get it.
Experts in the field are often
slightly more difficult.
To get in touch with, and
are best reached by using Twitter,
email, or phone.
Look for experts that are in your area,
or wait until you have an interactive
online prototype like the one
we'll be building with Envision.
The third and
fourth circles are often best reached
through Guerilla prototyping.
You can often find someone who
matches your target demographic at
a coffee shop, and it's possible to
offer them coffee in exchange for
looking at your prototype.
Now, which of these can you
do as a solo entrepreneur?